hey what's up you beautiful souls
welcome to another episode of get close
I'm Geo I'm Bart do you know what even
says on your shirt collusion collusion
on my shirt yeah where the shirt besides
all the Chinese characters yeah these
are what it's a word yeah they're all
Chinese characters is it different
Chinese characters no just the same
thing but it's like one's upside down
one's right side up
this is Moon
really yes it's moon moon moon moon moon
moon moon moon moon
that's so cool yeah you it yeah damn
Chinese is so hard Mandarin is hard yeah
I hear Cantonese is even harder yeah I
think there's even more tones yeah than
I heard but I think it's like 14 tones
or 16 tones
that's amazing right like how um how uh
language is develop
do you ever study uh
etymology I think
no what is that it's the study of how
languages came to be so like like
because all languages they kind of have
a root yeah they keep going I wasn't a
loser I had like a real like really cool
like life and I had friends yeah I'm not
a loser either I'm just kidding I'm just
smart I didn't have any of that nor am I
[ __ ] smart oh I'm just curious like
for example Portuguese and Spanish very
close and then Italian might even be
kind of close too poor what do you mean
Portuguese in Spanish is very close I
don't understand any [ __ ] Portuguese
I mean you're not smart enough to but if
you open your mind up you could well
it's not about opening up my mind but
even like you know as a you've never
even heard the similarities as a kid
um Portuguese is one of those that is
like it's pretty hard Portuguese is it's
like saying French to English like well
not even no no that's pretty that's
pretty wrong yes that is wrong it's like
obviously the language is different
obviously
but when you start hearing the
mechanisms behind the language it's
Latin based yeah you're like yeah oh
[ __ ] I can see why they were both from
the got it what is it called Iberian
Peninsula or whatever you're like oh
like Cantonese Vietnamese very similar
is it Japanese Korean very similar oh
that is very so I didn't know I didn't
know uh Vietnamese and Cantonese is very
similar yeah
tone the way that things are expressed
like like like
um like no man that's like like [ __ ]
your mom right like uh Cantonese is
like a very it's like a like a that kind
of language I like hearing your dad when
he speaks Cantonese really yeah why uh
because it fits his texture of his voice
oh it's all raspy sounding yeah yeah
your dad actually has a really cool
voice but I think he because it's he's
speaking Mandarin it just sounds rough
because I think so I don't know [ __ ]
about Mandarin or Vietnam or uh uh
Cantonese but the way he speaks Mandarin
sounds like there's a thick
Cantonese accent tied to it yeah yeah I
don't know if I'm right there so it
sounds rough yeah even like your mom
when she speaks Mandarin hers doesn't
sound like a stereotypical Mandarin that
I would hear like on commercials or TV
or like shows yeah her sounds like it
also has like a slight twang no my mom
says it it doesn't no there's like
standard Mandarin is it yeah okay then
what the [ __ ] do I know but yeah your
dad's sounds rough I see but going back
to Portuguese yeah Portuguese like
that's that's the beauty of the
languages you can hear it that
Portuguese has Spanish and French
influence that's probably why it said
French but yeah you can hear it right
because I love the way like bonjour
right yeah and Portuguese has
that sound sexy
with the Spanish together yeah so that's
why like uh it's beautiful to go oh wow
like a lot of these cultures how did
they mean it's almost like food yeah
right you're like what the [ __ ] how come
so many cultures have dumplings and you
start tracing you're like yeah all
because of this this this and it all
goes back to it it all goes back to just
[ __ ] Chinese people though honestly
every time I hear anything in history
it's like they they [ __ ] discovered
tomatoes and did all this [ __ ] it's like
well the Chinese already did that [ __ ]
the root root when you bring it like all
those all these nations yeah when you
bring it down to the root there's
literally like I don't know like two or
three root cultures like you got Africa
uh you got China
I don't know what the white source is
but there's like the Vikings the the
what do they call the caucus yeah it
could be yeah it could be some sort of
Icelandic something yeah there's
literally just like a there is that that
slowly spread into like everything else
yeah
a lot of like the natives oh
and outside of like even Africa or like
regions of Africa they all look Asian
you know Africans look Asian to you no
no I said outside of of some of the the
African countries oh yeah yeah
um they all look eight like a lot of
like uh Latin American ones too they go
back to like the natives and they look
Asian oh yeah Taiwanese
um they are like like that an Indian
like Asian mix yeah you know or like
Polynesian looking yeah
yeah that's interesting huh well that
was a complete side tangent from what I
was going to ask you what I was going to
ask you was when was the last time you
were embarrassed
[Laughter]
because I think on social media I
actually [ __ ] hate this question you
know that really why
because I don't ever really have an
answer so either I'm embarrassed a lot
for like stupid little things
um or I'm rarely embarrassed because
um the things that I'm embarrassed about
aren't like your stereotypical like I
ran into a pool and there was like this
hot guy but that's fine looking you know
and then so I'll tell you the context if
I want to ask
is um I think for like a lot of people
especially the social media world right
everyone's putting their best foot
forward so it's so easy to assume how
perfect people's lives are right and
that's where you kind of have like this
like grass is greener kind of like
sentiment that we live in and then
that's why people sometimes feel sad
because we're like man everyone's life
is like how is this person living in
[ __ ] a Visa every day and then I'm
just like sure right but I'm like man
like everyone's a human being yeah
[ __ ] you've seen how many times Biden
has tripped and fell it's like if he
could trip without the funniest place
I've ever seen you make okay if I don't
know where you're going with it
president can trip and fall everyone can
trip and fall [ __ ] the hottest girl
some people trip and fall on like
[ __ ] soft [ __ ] silk carpet and
other people trip and fall on dog [ __ ]
you know what I mean this is a different
trip and fall yeah but we're all human
you know we're all human and we all
experience human stuff yeah like we all
should take a [ __ ] we've all shed our
underwear yeah like we live next door to
a celebrity and then like literally the
first week of us living here I look over
I was like
oh [ __ ] this celebrity's picking up dog
[ __ ] just like everybody else very true
you know so I'm just like like we all go
through it yeah so I'm like what are
some things that like
um but obviously we don't post our
embarrassments or whatever but I think
it's like a very relatable well I think
a lot of the [ __ ] that we do post is
pretty embarrassing to a lot of people
oh to a lot of people
um but when was the last time you were
embarrassed then even if it's small or
even if it's not a stereotypical thing
like Oh I'm a [ __ ] yeah yeah I [ __ ]
myself or whatever I think a lot of my
embarrassment and shame comes from like
my inability to like execute things or
reach my goals
right like like
um if I can't explain articulate
properly right like that's embarrassing
to me so every time we shoot a podcast a
lot of the times I can't watch my own
[ __ ] because I'm embarrassed of that but
the way you speak yeah sometimes oh you
know so like I'm more so embarrassed
about my own personal growth
all right why are you embarrassed about
that why why are you so much interesting
those are things that would that huh why
are you so embarrassed you can't talk
good it's well you can't speak well yeah
why can't you speak well
um you have no excuse all right you
[ __ ] trash bucket chill out all
right chill pickle God damn it Tyga
um but so that's where a lot of my
embarrassment comes from you know if I'm
not where I want to be then I'm like
embarrassed of that yeah but like
I guess I was talking about [ __ ] our
pants like you know when I have to take
shits in public that's pretty
embarrassing to me when's the last time
you took a [ __ ] in public the last time
I saw my girlfriends and like you know
we had our little high school Clique
reunion since then you haven't had a
[ __ ] incident or even a period or a
tampon incident I haven't had a tampon
period incident because over the years
I've mastered the leakages yeah so I'm
good there yeah but
um no I've shot after that but that was
on a hike no one was around it was just
me and taika and taika was like ew mom
why are you pooping after that yeah tell
me about that I told you we were on this
hike literally like two weeks ago in
Glendora and I was like this is where I
took a [ __ ] and it was like right around
the bed and I said a few minutes later a
lady and her kids was walked by and I
was like oh [ __ ] oh that wasn't me
he took a fat [ __ ] on a trail yeah like
you know when we're going up and it's
like on the side of a cliff yeah yeah I
had to take a [ __ ] like a tyson-sized
[ __ ] uh it was kind of like
uh I don't know if it was Tyson size but
it was definitely half solid half watery
don't [ __ ] judge me like you [ __ ]
did you excuse yourself did you have to
take a stand like away from you yeah I
said taika mama has to poop I'm so sorry
dude then you just left them
unsupervised like that no I was watching
like don't move I'm like stay right
there and he goes ew Mom are you pooping
and I was like I'm sorry son I don't
walk me through it what'd you do did you
pull it down your ankles uh so we were
on this hike and this hike is about like
three maybe three four miles long but it
feels like it can be longer because most
of the time depending on the direction
you start how we started it's more
uphill so like you go uphill and like
like the walkway in certain areas is
literally like a couple feet wide oh
it's one of those where it's like a
sharp drop yeah so taika and I couldn't
I couldn't walk so we couldn't walk side
by side and he's just a little a little
body right yeah so he had to either walk
in front of me or like walk like
slightly to the side of me like away
from the cliff so so um we're like in
the thick of it right in the middle and
you know how sometimes I get those heavy
shits out of nowhere yeah like I don't
even know what I ate usually it's Korean
barbecue or ice cream yeah it has to be
like a a rich fatty thing that I eat and
but I don't or maybe it was like my
morning poops and I had coffee and I
just made the [ __ ] dire mistake of
drinking before a hike so stupid and
like um so it must have been something I
ate so we're literally in the middle of
like the peak of the hardest part of
this this
um this hike and taika looks so cute
like he's wearing like nice uh shorts
his little hat because it's a hot day he
has his little hiking boots on I don't
know why you weren't there maybe you
were filming or some [ __ ] or maybe I'm
probably back here with my dad no no we
lived in Glendora still oh we live in
the Glendora still yeah oh [ __ ] so those
tacos little little like two yeah yeah
he was younger okay and um yeah and I
was like oh [ __ ] I have to poop yeah
like it's just that sinking feeling and
I'm like [ __ ] so first it starts off
with like the bubble guts a little bit
yeah and you could kind of sometimes you
can get away with it the bubble guts if
if it's more gassed and [ __ ] yeah so if
you fart here and there like you can
prolong the [ __ ] like sometimes if one
fart might equate to 10 more minutes
yeah you're just kind of letting
releasing the the pressure yeah yeah
exactly yeah so maybe I farted a couple
times and I was like okay cool I feel
good but those won't stink though those
those are rough you smelled it oh yeah
and it's kind of like those are those
pungent ones you see why I'm not
embarrassed like look at this [ __ ] and
they're kind of warm too it is warm but
it's not one of those where it's like
was that a shark it was like definitely
those types of smell it like whoa Mama
dude sometimes I feel so bad because I'm
tall right 5 11. this kid is like right
well he's a little bit taller now but he
was always at crotch but whole area like
height yeah man sometimes he would come
on a hug and I just finished farting and
I'm like oh no dude but he never said
anything oh I don't know if he just
doesn't maybe he's just like Ugh or at
that time he was still in his own
diapers where he's like I always smell
like this
he's like this is no different than what
I I don't know what kids smell you know
yeah now he's [ __ ] very aware of like
did you just fart is that fart who
farted like he's all [ __ ] fart police
yeah
um no but at that time yeah peak of
maybe it was even summertime but it was
[ __ ] hot so for farted and I thought
I was in the safe Zone and it's one of
those where it's like not [ __ ] you just
rushed it like you just pushed it a
little too far close or a little too
close to the butthole now it needs to
come out and I'm like no way and I'm
like thinking like [ __ ] how am I gonna
wipe my ass because I you know me I like
to travel with nothing like I'm a
minimal traveler I don't have purse like
if I can leave my keys behind and just
open my car with my phone I'm just doing
that yeah because I'm the one holding
everything shut the [ __ ] up what do I
bring what is my day like my keys can
you hold my keys can you hold my wallet
my keys in my wallet are attached to one
thing I'm holding your [ __ ] and I'm like
why don't you ever get anything with
pockets [ __ ] off you rarely hold myself
you just had a bottle Brigade photo
shoot and guess who's carrying your [ __ ]
off who was carrying your [ __ ] too what
are you talking about carrying my own
[ __ ] no I only wanted you to carry my
[ __ ] because we're in a sketchy ass area
where I just didn't want someone to
swipe my [ __ ] I don't need you yeah you
do he literally can't live without me
sometimes anyway so then
um
yeah so you don't have any napkins or
anything yeah I'm like trying to
strategize because I'm like I was in a
vulnerable spot too like if like this
was a a castle or if this is my land and
I'm getting attacked by the enemy I have
no sight of like what's coming from
either end oh you know and it was one of
those things
yeah yeah so I'm like at the at the
outside of the curb here why did you
choose that area to go I wasn't trying
to but it's I'm telling you it was such
a narrow walkway and I needed so I'm
looking for
um uh I'm looking for coverage I'm
looking for so my own ass coverage but
also [ __ ] coverage because this is just
dirt we just kick dirt at it I could but
it's not like a lot of loose dirt it's
just ground like it's just like the hard
dirt you know I mean like there's not a
lot I could kick on it
um I'm looking uh to to make sure like
up because above me it's still like part
of the trail below me I think I'm fine
um and how my [ __ ] where do I hide like
it was such a vulnerable spot so I'm
like [ __ ] man okay well I think this is
fine and I kind of looked around and
it's so quiet there that I'm like okay I
think I can hear people coming so I like
I waited
and I hear nothing and I'm like all
right this is it pulls out my pants take
my ankles or to the knees
um to the ankles for sure and it's one
of those where you have to like Pull It
Forward you want to [ __ ] on your stuff
you don't want some splashing to happen
you know what I mean
um and it's one of those where like you
have to aim your butthole like parallel
to the floor like it can't be in like it
has to be precise like you know like the
the leveler yeah like that bubble has to
be in the middle perfectly in the middle
yeah
um what [ __ ] just running around no
of course not because it says [ __ ]
narrow Steep Hill that we're on not to
move so I told him to like look at me
well I'm just like stand right there I
need to see you dude and he's just he's
like in disbelief that his mom now is
just a [ __ ] animal yeah a [ __ ] dog
taking a [ __ ] well he just couldn't
believe it he's like Mom what are you
doing oh my God yeah yeah he's like Mom
are you pooping Mom are you pooping at
this point he's already potty trained
too and I was like [ __ ] dude I'm like
yeah monkey I have I have an emergency
Mama Can't hold it and I had to find
like this like leaf and I'm like [ __ ]
dude because in these parts there's like
poison ivy in there yeah it's the wild
poison ivy poison oak yeah yeah it's not
like a [ __ ] uh what is it called uh
uh preserve you know where it's like
maintained by people yeah it's just if a
tree falls it's just chilling there now
it's part of this landscape like no
one's going to [ __ ] scoop [ __ ] up
yeah so like I'm like grabbing a leaf
and I'm going [ __ ] how do I know that
I'm not gonna get a rash or like some
[ __ ] poison from this and I'm like
[ __ ] it I don't know what to do so I
contemplated oh you wiped with the leaf
yeah I contemplated a couple things to
not even wipe one of those was that okay
but I [ __ ] was wearing a stupid ass
thong that now that I'm older I hate
songs we'll get into that they are hot
but who am I trying to impress you me no
so now I like I love [ __ ] grandma
underwear but that's for another God
you're [ __ ] old as [ __ ] it's
comfortable dude yeah that's what an old
person you wear you wear a [ __ ] thong
if you're so sexy I wear sexy boxer
briefs like every other Calvin Klein
model yeah but they're not sexy yeah
they are fine
um
so yeah so there's just so many
strategic moves that I have to make at
this point so luckily it was one of
those as soon as I get into position it
all comes out within seconds out of my
system yeah like I didn't have to sit
there my butthole wasn't like dry
heaving to get the last part out you
know what I mean it's because sometimes
it'll feel a little bit stuck like no it
was like ready to [ __ ] in nature in the
full squat position it was amazing
actually feels really really good I
loved it it just smells so bad because
it doesn't go into water where it just
gets sealed yes it goes on the floor and
you God this smells like [ __ ] yeah
little [ __ ] but your own [ __ ] is never
like intolerable I mean you kind of like
it yeah I'm glad you said that because I
didn't hate it but it still smells like
[ __ ] yeah absolutely it's disgusting
like if it's someone else's [ __ ] I'm
like oh
just I'm about to throw up just thinking
about it but if it's my own [ __ ] I'm
like oh okay I did have
uh I don't know garlic sauce I can smell
it a little bit like the garlic well
great because you're thinking of my [ __ ]
but think of your own [ __ ] and it's not
that disgusting it is still this the
taika smell it
you know he has funny proportions right
now yeah so like our hand to face ratio
yeah is pretty similar yeah whereas
taikas is like his my fist yeah to my to
my head that's like his ratio yeah yeah
so he's gone
not even Fanning [ __ ] he's like
this little hat little ass hands and
I'll never forget it because his head's
so massive compared to his [ __ ] footy
and he just it's like his [ __ ] Idol
yeah became like diminished in seconds
just watching me squat like a [ __ ]
neanderthal
and then what'd you do did you kick it
did you of course so I was so polite
that I didn't do it in the trail so I
like it was on the bend on the outskirts
of the bed right yeah and there was like
this bush so I was able to kind of tuck
my ass into this bush yeah put it there
and then cover it up with like Dead
Leaves and [ __ ] yeah
um so it was like beautiful so then I
wipe with the [ __ ] random ass leaf
that I found I made sure it was still
alive
um because you don't want that hard
abrasive oh yeah uh and then yeah I was
I was done I still had like moist butt
you know what I mean because it's not
paper it's not absorbent it's disgusting
so I'm like [ __ ] I really gotta change
this [ __ ] thong it was rough and then
literally like a minute later
a lady and her kid walks by and I'm like
[ __ ] or like they started catching up to
because I recognize it did they go whoa
smell did you smell I don't know I left
to see the crime scene as quickly as I
was able to cover it yeah I bounced I'm
like none of this happened taika stare
into my pen and I erased his memory you
know like he we just moved it we moved
on we started Living our life and then
like that's when a minute later they
were like behind us and I'm like holy
[ __ ] so I played it off hey what's up
and then
worst case scenario she calls me out on
it I'd be like yeah my poor son he's not
feeling too good so I had a little
scapegoat you wouldn't even have
admitted it like yeah you know when they
called oh Nature Calls no my poor baby
like he just he probably ate something
bad they're gonna be like that's like
straight a bag of brown marshmallows
there's no way he's that little guy he
eats a lot I can't believe we just threw
him on the bus have you seen Tyga's [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] massive dude first time I
saw him [ __ ] in a toilet I was like how
the [ __ ] did this come out of you
exactly and he doesn't even eat that
much so of course it's believable man
I'm fine if I eating all kinds of snacks
he has some Hefty [ __ ] or maybe it's
just his pipes are really clean that
there's nothing staying in there whereas
like our pipes over the years have built
some some Gunk it's crazy that he's so
young
and he [ __ ] Outdoors you've seen you
[ __ ] Outdoors we've all peed Outdoors
together we haven't chat with him
outdoors I don't think I've chat with
him but we've definitely like crossed
streams in Hawaii multiple times yeah
yeah but it's he's probably like we've
crossed tyke and I have crossed the
streams yeah it's probably like in his
brain it's like
this is what life is about it is
literally remember we were looking for
houses for your dad yeah in that one
retirement community so we're with our
Realtor Christina yeah yeah and um was
my mom I think my mom was with us too
yeah yeah she was like maybe checking it
out too just scoping it out yeah yeah
she was with us and I think I always
like to stay with my mom because you and
your dad have to be together because he
only speaks Chinese you're translating
and this was specifically for your dad
yeah so like I think I'm letting you
three like Christina you and her do your
own thing and I'm I think taika was
playing with you guys in the backyard or
something yeah and then you guys come
back in because I'm with my mom and
you're like you're not gonna believe
what Tyga just did and I could hear you
guys going like oh no actually I take
that back it was like no wait wait
because Christina's going no no no no no
no no no no
for Christina
and then I look and I see his little
[ __ ] ass cheeks yeah pissing in the
backyard of someone else's house that
we're checking out yeah it's an open
house because at this time I think we we
had just solidified
um him feeling comfortable to uh not
wear diapers anymore yeah or pull-ups
yeah yeah and um so the way that we
taught we were potty training him was
one keeping him naked or like outside
um we would just let him pee wherever he
needed to pee so he started equating I
have to pee to just pee whatever you
want because that's what I do at home so
that's what I'm that's just what we do
yeah we gotta pee we just pull our pants
down
[ __ ] guy dude yeah I forgot about
that then she came back
it's so CUNY yeah but um I guess yeah me
having to pee in public or or not even
pee in public but me having to do
bathrooms in public
out in the open
not even like public restrooms just like
nature shits and I'm not camping that's
pretty rough for me what's crazy is I
think
um
before I think that that might be the
only thing I'm embarrassed about
is like [ __ ] I have to [ __ ] because it's
one of those like if I I usually can
hold my [ __ ] pretty good but if I need
to [ __ ] it's like oh oh Panic time what
do you mean by you can hold your [ __ ]
pretty good because we've ran a lot of
red lights literally yesterday we were
on our regular walk you had to run back
home like what are you how are you
holding how long were you holding it
prior to that then because it doesn't
sound like you have a very big window
well I guess what I'm saying is I
haven't had those urges that much
um but now they're coming out of nowhere
because before it'd be like oh yeah I
drink vodka and milk together so like
I'm gonna have some crazy shits later
that's some throat
yeah but like this now it's just like my
regular life
and maybe I missed time my caffeine or
something and I've just had to have
these like so the other one was
yesterday with you I'm with you I'm
never embarrassed right because you're
my CUNY mama so I was like we're just
walking back and I'm like oh [ __ ] I
gotta go so I just started [ __ ]
running yeah I was like see you later
but as soon as I have that feeling
there's always a one percent thought of
like [ __ ] do I just gotta pull my pants
down [ __ ] right here really like even
yesterday you thought that because I was
just running and I was like [ __ ] I feel
it oh it was to the point where I'm like
it might just come out by itself I'm not
even pushing no yeah do you ever give up
where you're like that's this is it this
is the day that I [ __ ] in my [ __ ]
pants I've never given up I mean don't
give in to that but like do you just
admit it now where you're like this is
the day I [ __ ] on myself I always have
that I always have the always I always I
always have a prepare for the worst case
scenario yeah like [ __ ] it I'm just it's
gonna [ __ ] happen but then what what
places has that happened a lot of places
like where give me some I will but I'm
gonna explain to you my thought process
so there's a lot of places where I'm
like [ __ ] it I'm just gonna get I'm just
uh
today it could be the day
but I'm also in my mind I'm a warrior so
I'm never gonna let that happen on my
watch so you know when you like so for
dudes when they're about to come
you can either
I'm Gonna Come
or I'm gonna keep the stimulation going
and it's just gonna come on its own can
girls do that
no oh really yeah
so dudes could be like all right I'm
gonna [ __ ] be active about this come
and I'm just gonna come right now but I
can also be passive about it and just
let my body do what it wants to do so
when it comes to [ __ ] I feel the
same way right I can [ __ ] [ __ ] right
now I'm [ __ ] push hard it's gonna
[ __ ] or I'm gonna be like I'm gonna keep
holding on to it but if my body doesn't
agree with me it's just gonna [ __ ] on
its own so I so I always just
defer to that and that's a very
uncomfortable feeling it's the same
feeling as you know when you gotta pee
and you gotta pinch it off it's like the
opposite of that okay I mean how hard is
it for you to pee and then [ __ ] go
I'm not gonna pee right now very hard
right it was impossible yeah it's almost
impossible it's like the opposite of
that yeah when you're like okay I want a
[ __ ] but I'm just gonna not even gonna
[ __ ] unless my body wants to do it so I
had that yesterday where I was [ __ ]
running back and I'm like oh [ __ ] I
might just [ __ ] [ __ ] on my shorts
right now wow that was an emergency then
yeah but I was able to make it inside
thank God the next one right before that
was I don't know if my body is good with
sushi anymore because uh after the
barber Brigade meat me me and Silent
Mike uh and uh Nadine we went to go eat
sushi where
um oh okay and then
um I thought you guys went again and I
was like oh no it was at night time okay
so we ate sushi and then afterwards I
was like hey guys you just want to go in
for a walk because I gotta go and walk
and they're like oh sure I'll go wanna
walk with you so we go around the
neighborhood around the park whatever
and then on my way back
um I was on the other side of the street
oh [ __ ] I think I got a [ __ ] and then
they're like oh what are you gonna do
and then like you could tell that these
guys aren't like regular [ __ ] yeah
because they're like all polite and [ __ ]
they're like oh do you want to go to
like the
um did you just don't know how Savage
you are yeah you want to go to like the
gas station right there or whatever yeah
they're humans baby and I was like no
we're we're garbage I'm gonna go into
that restaurant that they just saw me at
right now and they're like oh fair and
they're like wait but we're not eating
dirty mama I don't give a [ __ ] they said
that that doesn't matter I guess they're
like I already gave you my money I have
access to your [ __ ] business I also
left but I gave you my money I still own
it so that's how I feel too so I'm glad
we're in the same religion so I was like
you know what you saw me paid yeah so I
was like they didn't recognize this face
so I just sprinted across the street I
was just [ __ ] running running running
and you know those that like cute little
Japanese security guard hello he's
looking at me running across the street
like I'm gonna use the bathroom it was
okay oh he got it I go in the bathroom I
got it and then I [ __ ] [ __ ] and it
just felt so good and uh those are two
recent times
that it just [ __ ] hit me that's me
out of nowhere time
I don't know why I have that do I have
like IBS but that's me like all the time
usually I don't have that because I take
my caffeine in the mornings and I like
to I don't like to leave the house until
I've
pooped already yeah yeah I don't get to
time it sometimes it really is dependent
on my
um on on my body but now that I'm taking
a lot of supplementation like you know
every day I take all my barbell Subs I'm
not even trying to be [ __ ] pluggy
plugs yeah but like I love our subs yeah
that like now I'm pooping regularly
solid I don't have to run and [ __ ]
have the emergency but prior to taking
my Subs
um it was rough man like I would just
eat and everyone in my family everyone
in our friend's Circle knew that as soon
as we finished our meal within five
minutes Joe has to go poop yeah so we
couldn't have a good conversation or I
couldn't be part of the conversation
because I'm like sick okay now we're all
gonna relax oh God I gotta go take a
[ __ ] it was always like that
always like that and I've had those
moments where I'm like [ __ ] man today's
the day I'm gonna [ __ ] myself even like
in the bathroom waiting for the [ __ ]
stall to free up I'm like [ __ ] I'm just
standing there and I'm like damn this is
how it goes down
there's some times where I was like I
feel like I'm gonna grab the guy out of
the stall and throw him out oh I never
think of it because sometimes I'm like
[ __ ] this is way too long I know
you're on the phone and I want to just
kick the door open and grab them throw
them out I never think that I'm always
like I'm always like I picture it like
coming out of my [ __ ] ass as I'm
standing there and like spreading my
butt cheeks open and going like like
slowly like [ __ ] chocolate fudge just
like running down my leg and I'm like
this is it and then I start justifying
it going like okay well I think I can
get away with it yeah I might be stinky
for a bit but it won't seep through
because I'm wearing like denim or
whatever like I start strategizing like
how I'm Gonna Leave This area with [ __ ]
pants Oh the other time was uh when I
was back here and my dad wanted to go
eat so I was like okay like what can I
fit in my diet still my dad was still
like and then I'm like oh I'll go get
some prime rib with them so it went down
to South Point because I got a really
good uh slept on prime rib at the buffet
four very affordable prices yeah very
affordable price this podcast is brought
to you by just kidding and then I go
there and uh of course I get the rarest
the rare pieces gotta love that so both
me and my dad are eating having a good
old time and then he like his steak rare
too yeah he loves it like that he's the
one that taught me to get medium rare oh
not my family they're the opposite Asian
the way Asian dads explain things he
goes
um
you either get it medium rare or you're
a [ __ ] dumbass something okay you're
gonna medium rare you know yeah yeah you
guys are supposed to enjoy my family is
this day yeah and then uh afterwards I
was like oh cool I'm gonna get some
fruits you know get some Fiber going and
I don't know I don't know if I it was
the steak that made me have to go
probably the whole thing or the
pineapple that had a little bit of brown
on it oh Jesus Christ the pineapples
were good so I had a ton of those super
sweet good yeah so I was driving back on
the 15. how far of a drive are we
talking like a 10 minute drive 20 minute
drive South Point
back to here yeah how many minutes is
that like 20 30 20 minutes okay so I'm
driving and then I was like oh [ __ ] Dad
I think I gotta [ __ ] how far into the
drive like five minutes in no yeah oh
[ __ ] I [ __ ] and he goes really like how
bad I'm like really bad cute really all
bad yeah and then I was like I'm gonna
drive different okay and he goes like
okay so cute I'm going like buckle up
Dad it's gonna be a bumpy ride at home
like 60 on local ding ding ding ding
ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
ding yeah yeah
and then I saw uh a gas station but it's
one of those [ __ ] dumbass gas
stations where it's right here and then
here's the center Island [ __ ] off so you
can't turn into it you have to go all
the way to go and either go here and
then turn in from that side or you gotta
bust in you and make a right every
second exactly yes so as soon as I saw
that stupid ass [ __ ] Island I went no
I went uh against traffic on this side
good for you yeah so it's an emergency
yeah my dad's side whoa what are you
doing I told you yeah
so I drove in there I [ __ ] where with
the you know when you go pull into a
parking lot
going there and I was like I hope no
one's using the public bathroom or
[ __ ] running I spread my butt cheeks
you know it's just like
like that I'm like
are you like holding on to the [ __ ]
walls your feet are up yeah I'm like
what's wrong with bee's life I was like
Googling at the same time I'm like Prime
red bear steak really yeah
like a [ __ ] like going off-roading
what uh what prompted for this Google
Search because that doesn't sound oh you
just thought you got like food poisoning
no I'm just like why why is it like that
why does it happen like that because
like when I get those attacks like I
need answers I don't get them that often
I need answers uh maybe I just got used
I'm like whatever I need answers what
was the answer so
um in one of the things that I searched
if you eat meat too raw you can get
diarrhea I forgot what like uh
well like I don't know amino acid or
whatever it is but it can
have diarrhea and both me and my dad got
like two or three servings of prime rib
so it was a lot of rare meat what the
[ __ ] oh did you just do a buffet yeah
yeah
that's what I'm saying they got a really
slept on prime rib at the buffet got it
yeah so got it so uh yeah I had both me
and him had two or three services you
should probably have diarrhea too yeah
once he got home he got lucky maybe
because he's old was metabolism slower
uh but here's a damn are you okay I was
like yeah I'm good because after I came
home I had to [ __ ] some more too so I
[ __ ] probably like three or four times
and then um
and I was like cool I'm gonna go sleep
and in the morning that's my dad told me
this damn I [ __ ] like three times last
night too how do you say [ __ ] in
Mandarin uh if you say if you say that I
guess the kind of how did he say stop
yeah
why does that sound [ __ ] familiar
sounds like something else without being
means uh poop I'm gonna go poop like but
you wouldn't say it like that's not the
polite way to say it I see yeah like the
that'd be like seeing Oh I gotta take a
dump you know it's like that yucky but
then Mandarin is so [ __ ] polite that
even that even the not polite way of
saying it it's called you know what you
know what it literally means big
bien means inconvenience oh wow so I
gotta have a big inconvenience right now
oh wow but even that is considered
poetic yeah and then uh and then p is
Shelby like little inconvenience oh
oh that's cute so even that is still
like
that's cute how you have those moments
with your pop what a memorable moment
yeah he [ __ ] saw me go against
traffic and I could just see his eyes go
holy [ __ ] this guy's crazy
yeah there's been a lot of those times
with my mom in the car she already knows
she's one of those where she's like you
gotta go poop now and I'm like no
yeah I'll be back yeah I'm better now
but yeah and I wasn't embarrassed
because my dad you know right right when
was last time you were embarrassed
oh man exactly right it's not an easy
question
yeah you see that's what I think I was a
little bit embarrassed with silent Mike
when I had to poop because uh well we're
with Kyle and also sea bass and I don't
really know them oh I wouldn't give a
[ __ ] oh but I don't know them because
he's my homie but I'd also know they're
tight with him so for me I was just like
you know it is kind of weird when you're
just walking with the group and you're
like I got a [ __ ] and he just starts
sprinting I thought it was a guy thing
like I thought guys are just already
naturally gross yeah but not that gross
what what do you mean not that gross you
guys are farting in each other's faces
oh all right well I did I never knew a
guide to like like do you think her
brother if he's hanging out with like me
and maybe if some of my friends for the
first time he'd be like I gotta [ __ ] and
spread a block
maybe not my brother but I can watch him
you can see him sprinting a whole block
remember Alec he'd [ __ ] do that yeah
but he's not normal I think most guys
are like that no most most guys do not
want to be viewed in a vulnerable light
that's so vulnerable is it [ __ ]
if imagine your brother it's farting
[ __ ] dick jokes imagine your brother
needs the fart or needs to [ __ ] and he
starts running and I play defense in
front of him I don't let him go he's
gonna be worried he's gonna be [ __ ]
worried is that a guy I think what do
you
mean
playing defense yeah to [ __ ] around no I
mean it that's what I'm saying it's so
it's so vulnerable that at that moment
when I'm running across the street my
life isn't in my hands I see no one no
they were nice enough to not play
defense got it but if they wanted to
I'll do whatever they want yeah
I'm not gonna let you in the bathroom so
you give me 100 bucks I'm like [ __ ]
just cheers don't care
that's all I gotta do okay right that's
a vulnerable that's a vulnerable state
when you're [ __ ] sprinting across the
the street like that yeah that's true so
I was embarrassed because it is remember
your Crocs yeah oh God you're so [ __ ]
whack why because those Crocs are
[ __ ] they're so geeky looking dude
they're sick and then I can hear you
you're the one that told me to get Crocs
no I didn't you got Crocs yeah that's me
because I'm cool I don't even wear them
now I am cool no I didn't tell you to
get you got them because you wanted to
match with taika because taika looks so
cute and that's [ __ ] cute it looks
really cute but the way yours like I
think is you're so dense and heavy yeah
like yours start like I just feel bad
for those Crocs because they get [ __ ]
smushed oh
smushed then I can hear like your sticky
feet inside of them yeah so I was kind
of embarrassed a little bit you should
be you were wearing Crocs and running
across the street across the street yeah
and I was like oh my God what the [ __ ]
going on yeah at the time I thought I
was gonna [ __ ] myself
um not on the hike but after seeing my
girlfriends uh I was gonna poop and like
so I always I always like to keep a
trash can
or like a little trash box bin yeah yeah
in my car because I mean [ __ ] mom
life yeah
and I was like [ __ ]
I'm strategizing again I'm like I think
I'm just gonna have to [ __ ] in there and
hope that there's no holes in the
[ __ ] little bucket and then I was
down to like drive with it back home how
stupid is that
I should just throw it away I would have
found the nearest dumpster and tossed it
yeah well I didn't do that I ended up
just [ __ ] in front of my car on the
floor in a [ __ ] open parking lot
hoping that nobody saw anything and I
was like searching like looking up in
the ceiling and going like [ __ ] are
there any cameras here because holy [ __ ]
you guys are gonna about to get [ __ ]
were you embarrassed by yourself
yeah because I looked cute too oh I was
wearing like this cute little skirt oh I
wasn't little like it was a like a
longer skirt yeah but I looked very
feminine you know what I mean like I
didn't just finish training where it's
like oh it's expected she looks [ __ ]
trashy like of course trashy looking
people do trashy things no I looked very
refined you know yeah I looked classy I
look like I don't [ __ ] I look like a
female that has never shot in her life
you do look very pretty well at that
time thank you though but at that time
I'd look like I don't produce my body
doesn't produce those foul things yeah
you know and then for me to have to pick
that up and that was very shaming you
know it was like such a beautiful silk I
can't even look at the skirt anymore you
can't wear no more because I think of
that when have you seen me wear it oh
that's true it's a very nice skirt and I
think about it and I'm like
yeah one day I would like to [ __ ] in
nature
like like squat down full Squat and
scream well I'm shitty like just like
like I wonder how good that would feel
well why not a grunt right because
grunting because I do that at home
because you're like so it's like the
same yeah but you do that at home you're
like
but it's a right like do that now like
you're already like you're sphincter but
I do that at home I did a home already
but a scream you have to get your
sphincter gets tight yeah but I wanna I
wanna do like a war cry like
and just like that it all come out I
wonder if it like that's how it's
supposed to do it
try it I mean we live right next to a
[ __ ] big ass Hill mountain or
whatever you call that so on our next
hike we'll go to Red Rock well why why
do I gotta be there I don't want to be I
have to share that experience with
someone Vlog it what Vlog it really yeah
I mean but don't do a close-up maybe
just like put it behind a rock and it's
just auditory like it's just all audio
no it's
I'll probably side Vlog it so you can't
see my anus or my dick but I think like
that's probably one of the most fraying
things you can do because you're just
like you're like giving back to Mother
Nature you know for all the good things
Mother Nature is like [ __ ] I don't want
that I get shut on all day I know but
they want it and then you let it all out
and then you get to like let some of the
Demons come out of your soul through the
screen too
I think that'd be awesome because I've
already [ __ ] in water yeah
yeah you want it out in the open and
I've done that and you know what the
best [ __ ] is what when you're stuck like
you know that stuck [ __ ] feeling I can't
believe it
says when you're constipated yeah and
like you just get stuck you don't
[ __ ] hate constipation right and then
you finally like because you go to the
bathroom thinking like today's the day
like I've never been constipated oh
yeah well I get constipated every month
because of my period
but like before I start I ever got
constipated yeah is I've never been
constipated
but the closest I ever get I've never
been constipated that's amazing comes
out awesome I eat my veggies so but you
don't even eat veggies that's the crazy
part the closest I get is like this I'm
sitting on the toilet and you know how
usually it's like it comes out at the
rate of your push
if you push slow then it comes out
slower yeah right but then there's times
where you're pushing hard as [ __ ] and
it's barely moving you're like
yeah yeah yeah and then the constipation
it's almost as if like a alien is being
born because you can almost feel like
it's like
whoa why is it stretching my [ __ ]
[ __ ] and I can almost hear my [ __ ]
ripping
like it sounds like it's like you know
what like you're missing fiber dude you
need to [ __ ] start taking this if you
know those avian birth sound effects
where it's like
we're like the the Folly is actually
cabbage yeah it's like I could just feel
my [ __ ] [ __ ] like dilating bigger
than it's ever been yeah like that
like that and then I'm like
almost to the point where I feel like
like is it going inside or outside I
don't even know yeah and it comes out
and then I'm like
it's a diameter that I'm like it's not I
don't think it's humanly possible and
then huh
and they go
no no there's a bra it's like a big
[ __ ] solid thing and then I look down
and there's no wrinkles on it it's just
[ __ ] smooth
that's the closest I ever get to
constipation
there's no wrinkles on it not when it's
one of those because I think it's so
[ __ ] girthy that as it's coming out
it's like so packed that it's so smooth
there's no wrinkles that was one thing
my mom observed about your dad she goes
hey is Bart's dad like okay I'm like why
uh she's like he never eats any
vegetables I'm like yeah neither does
Bart and they're both [ __ ] super
healthy people like they have regular
shits all the goddamn time
my dad eats vegetables what vegetables
all he's eating is dumplings exactly
there's almost no vegetables dumplings
are half veggies
but the amount of Veggie to the rate
like the ratio read all the bags pork
and cabbage dumplings or pork and chives
dumplings or whatever and scallions like
they're literally half veggies yeah but
these are like the smallest [ __ ] you
need leafy green veggies you need tomato
you need variation like what you just
named our [ __ ] garnishes bro no
they're all great it's a [ __ ] garnish
they're off you said chives I throw that
at the end of the [ __ ] dish when it's
done well you could do it at the
beginning too yeah but it's [ __ ]
small it's just for flavor it's not for
anything else it's half veggies in there
trust me dude let's talk to a doctor
doctor to be like that's not enough you
should be having more veggies than carbs
or [ __ ] protein
maybe he does and you just don't know he
might be eating fruits
he never eats it
eats it it's a healthy dude
well he's drinking that [ __ ] herbal
tea there's probably whatever the [ __ ]
in there
yeah that's all he drinks too yeah his
[ __ ] potions what is what did like
regular drinks taste like to him because
you know when you have had like a clean
diet and then you go to something that's
way more processed and it's just the
flavors are just too robust like too
decadent you know what I mean like it's
just too rich I don't know he's trying
to be good like he loves cheesecake he
told me but he rarely eats it
because this G Series one of his
favorite things in the world I didn't
know that yeah I just found that out
like literally this year oh [ __ ] when
did he say that
um I think he went uh
uh meal prep shopping with me oh and he
saw it and he was like oh and I was like
he's like oh what's that that you're
getting I'm like it kind of tastes like
a cheesecake and then he goes oh I love
cheesecake
and he goes oh but I can't eat it it's
so bad for you is there a cheesecake in
Asian Cuisine like in Chinese food oh
okay just somehow because that's why my
mind was blown that he's never had an
avocado
because I'm like oh okay so you're just
you just really stick to that thing yeah
but cheesecake is way way more rare than
enough avocado is like a Spanish thing
yeah but everyone uses avocado no one
more people are using avocado for who
only Spanish things have avocados in it
salads have avocados because it's
Spanish it's not a Spanish salad it's
just a salad and it's a [ __ ] healthy
fat and they throw that in there because
of Spanish people
because avocado I mean uh cheesecake is
so funny when's the last time you saw
avocado in France
I hadn't been to France in a few years
all right I don't know what they put in
there okay when we go eat [ __ ]
Shawarma kebabs how many avocados you
see they have it in the salad no they
don't
I don't know I'm trying to just remember
and they have like a tomato and cucumber
salad yeah and it just it feels like
there's avocado side wants to throw it
in there because it's bomb there's no
avocado in Cantonese well it you can you
have to admit it sounds ridiculous that
he likes cheesecake and not avocado it's
not ridiculous because he's eating
American food before
and he's had cheesecake what's American
food
it's a [ __ ] Smorgasbord of [ __ ]
all of these other cultures now but that
that's a recent thing recent and how
long dude in like the last five ten
years what what the [ __ ] are you talking
about okay you go to like a [ __ ] a
Claim Jumpers okay in 1980 you tell me
if there's avocado in their menu you
said 10 years ago Dude I know we're in
[ __ ] 2020. so I'm pre-dating that and
I'm 120. yeah you go to Claim Jumpers
now they probably have a Santa Fe salad
or something yeah they've had that since
like the [ __ ] 80s dude no no no in
1980 okay maybe they go to Acclaim
jumpers or even an IHOP and I guarantee
you there's no avocado
now yeah they probably got the [ __ ]
Southwest Skillet with the [ __ ]
avocado in there I don't know but once
we started getting into the the [ __ ]
healthy food craze more than ever
avocado was a healthy fat and top of the
[ __ ] list okay so your dad loves to
watch [ __ ] news and this [ __ ] news
circulates everywhere so I just thought
he just interacted with avocados I don't
even know if they sell avocados at 99
Ranch they absolutely do
you want to bet no because I'm not sure
I've seen C well I don't know the
[ __ ] I'm a better I live in Vegas
it's [ __ ] gamble let's [ __ ] dance
yeah so I don't even think they have
that but cheesecake makes way more sense
because that's International you got
cheesecakes at Asian bakeries all right
that's fair yeah yeah that's a good
point [ __ ] all of this for that you know
what I'm done I'm done talking we're out
of here okay what else you got to talk
about [ __ ] no that's it thank God I
can't believe we just talked about [ __ ]
for that long well because it's very
Primal yeah we all [ __ ] we all do and as
we get older we give less [ __ ] and we
[ __ ] more yes I love it
detective doesn't really get embarrassed
either it seems like no which is CUNY
because that makes me feel like we're
really doing a good job of preserving
his little childhood yeah it is CUNY
because he doesn't seem like he's like
embarrassed to tell us anything he just
tells us and we always support him yeah
do you want a piece of him or the whole
thing yeah a piece of me you're a piece
of me you're a piece of me at the whole
thing it's like damn that's a good
threat yeah I don't want either one
[ __ ] violent guy yeah okay well thank
you big CUNY this was fun thank you and
thank you guys so much for listening
we'll catch you guys next week bye